ميسي يصل الرياض فما القصه في عيد العمال
برشلونه يخالف القانون بسبب لميمال
ومودريتش يلجا للطبيبه المعجزه فهل يلحق
بموقعه السيتي ونجم مانشستر يونايتد
السابق من الثراء الفاحش الى الافلاس هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم عبر قناه
العربيه رياضه اسعدوا لمتابعتكم
اثار مقطع فيديو متداول للارجنتيني ليونيل
ميسي حاله جدل واسعه على السوشيال ميديا
الفيديو يشير الى وصول لاعب باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي وعائلته الى السعوديه في
الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم في زياره
تستمر ليومين طبقا لاتفاقيه وقعها مع
وزاره السياحه السعوديه بغرض الترويج
للمملكه ومع هذا كله اثار وصول البرغوث
جدلا واسعا واصطحاله من الشك حول مستقبله
في حديقه الامراء او عودته الى ناديه
السابق برشلونه وتكاهنات انتقاله الى
الدوري السعودي
ننتقل الى الكرواتي لوكا مودريتش الذي
استغل عطله نهايه الاسبوع وتوجه الى مدينه
بلغراد والسبب بحسب التقارير الصحفيه
لرؤيه ماريجانا وهي طبيبه تعرف باسم
الدكتوره المعجزه لاعب ريال مدريد
الاسباني يامل بزيارته التقليصه مده
تعافيه من اصابه في اوتار الركبه واللحاقي
بموقعتين نهائي كاس الملك ومانشستر سيتي
لذهاب نصف نهائي دوري الابطال بفضل ما
يوصف بسحر ماريجانا صحيفه اسيا الاسبانيه
اوضحت ان هذه الطبيبه فعلت ما يشبه
المعجزه مع نجم تنس الصربي نوفاك ديكوفيتش
الذي كان يعاني من مشكله عضليه قبل اسابيع
فقط من بطوله استراليا المفتوحه والتي توج
بها بدايه العام الحالي
نتحول الى برشلونه حيث تسبب المغربي
لمينيمال في ازمه للنادي وذلك بالتزامن مع
احتفالات العالم اليوم بعيد العمال صحيفه
موندو
اكدت ان اشراك يامال ضد بيتيس قبل بلوغه
عمر السادسه عشر عاما يعتبر خرقا لقوانين
العمال في اسبانيا وتحديدا الماده السادسه
وكذلك اللائحه القانونيه التي تحضر عمل
القصر لساعات اضافيه ووضعهم في عروض عامه
مثل المباريات او المسرحيات ولسماح
للاعبين القصار بالمشاركه ان نادي مطالب
بوجود ابن كتابي
الختام مع وسبراون مدافع مانشستر يونايتد
الانجليزي السابق الذي بات احدث اعضاء
نادي اللاعبين المفلسين في سماء كره القدم
العالميه وبحسب فان ابن الثالثه والاربعين
عاما قد اعلن افلاسه اثر خسارته لملايين
الجنيهات في صفقات عقاريه فاشله حطمت ثروه
اللاعب السابق للشياطين الحمر ويعيش
اللاعب حاليا في بيت مستاجر من قبل زميله
ماركوس راشفورد براون اعلن فصاله قبل اشهر
قليله من زوجته ليان بسبب وضعه المالي غير
المستقر